In 2018, a truly original horror film called
A Quiet Place premiered at SXSW.
The buzz was fast and furious much like the
film's truly terrifying creatures.
Next year, we'll be getting a sequel to A
Quiet Place.
Here's everything we know so far.
“ahhh”
A few weeks after the U.S. release of A Quiet
Place on April 6th, 2018, Paramount Pictures
announced that a sequel was officially happening.
This wasn't terribly surprising news after
all, the film was a monster hit right out
of the gate.
It also happened to be directed by John Krasinski,
a multi-talented actor best known for his
turn in The Office.
"When you were in the office earlier talking
to Wallace, did I come up at all?"
"Uh…
Well, we did talk about how handsome you are."
Krasinski also co-starred and co-wrote the
screenplay for A Quiet Place.
Ultimately, he helmed a thoroughly engaging
fright-fest that was basically begging for
a follow up, albeit quietly.
The sequel was originally set to premiere
on May 15th, 2020, but the powers that be
moved up that date to March 20th, 2020.
Long story short: We won't have to wait much
longer to see the next installment.
As of the making of this video, the film doesn't
have an official title.
In a July 2019 Twitter post, actor and director
John Krasinski shared a slate from production
that simply read "Part II," so there's that.
But as of now, the film's title could be pretty
much anything.
It could be
A Quiet Place 2: Keep Quiet
An Even Quieter Place
A Quiet Place 2: Return to SHH!
The possibilities are endless.
Expect to see some familiar faces in the sequel.
In early 2019, it was confirmed that actress
Emily Blunt John Krasinski's wife in real
life would be returning to play Evelyn Abbott.
And there's more good news: Co-stars Millicent
Simmonds and Noah Jupe will be back to play
Regan and Marcus Abbott.
So if you've been eager to catch up with the
Abbott family, you're in luck.
However, it's still unclear whether Krasinski
will be appearing in the film.
We're... guessing not.
The world of A Quiet Place is… well, it's
very, very quiet.
Except when it's not.
“Ahh”
Throughout the first film, we pretty much
stick with the Abbott family though we do
meet another ill-fated survivor.
“Ahh”
It's a very brief, very brutal moment… but
it shows us that the Abbotts aren't alone.
As John Krasinski told Deadline in May 2018:
“The thing that I loved in the movie [...] was
the question of who was on the other end of
those fires, when the father lights the fire
and in the distance those other fires light
up.
How did those people survive?”
Looks like we may find out.
There's going to be some new, totally panicked
faces in the sequel.
In March 2019, Cillian Murphy of Peaky Blinders
was reportedly in talks to join the cast.
"It was meant to be routine."
In June 2019, it was announced that Atlanta
actor Brian Tyree Henry was also cast in the
film — but scratch that!
Deadline reported in August 2019 that Djimon
Hounsou was replacing him,
due to Henry having a scheduling conflict.
As we mentioned, John Krasinski didn't just
direct and star in A Quiet Place he also co-wrote
the screenplay.
Although writers Scott Beck and Bryan Woods
are credited with the first film's original
story, Krasinski ultimately rewrote the script.
This time around, Krasinski is the director
and the sole screenwriter, according to IMDb.
That's an exciting development, and we can't
wait to see what he's cooking up for us.
Intriguingly, he told The New York Times in
January 2019:
"I do have sort of a parental feeling about
this movie, and I don’t want A Quiet Place
to turn into an action movie where 400 people
have machine guns.
Or did I give away the ending to the sequel?"
Hey, we would totally watch that.
So what exactly do we know about the ghastly
creatures in A Quiet Place?
Not a whole lot.
They're presumably extraterrestrials, and
they obviously have extra-sensitive hearing.
Oh, and they've wiped out most of humanity.
They're kind of a big deal.
Will we be learning more about these vicious
jerks in the sequel?
Before leaving the project, actor Brian Tyree
Henry dropped a rather tantalizing morsel.
In June 2019, he told The Observer:
"I think that we’re also going to get a
few answers to the origin of where and how
this whole thing happened.
I think that people want to know that.
But I think you’re just going to see another
side of it…more of humanity that survived
this thing in this next story."
And that's all we know about the sequel right
now.
John Krasinski and his cohorts have remained
remarkably tight-lipped about the upcoming
horror film which is really rather appropriate,
isn't it?
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.